OK, let's talk a little bit about Tara Reid.
Tara Reid is the woman who accused Joe Biden
of sexual assault.
Now, I'm not here to evaluate her claims to
play tit for tat to debunk things.
I'm getting a lot of emails from people saying,
David, I need you to go through the evidence.
Did she do it or didn't she did did she do
it?
Meaning did she filed a complaint or didn't
she filed a complaint?
Did Biden do it or did he not do it?
I'm not able to do that, and nor do I think
it's the appropriate thing to do.
What I am here to tell you is from a political
standpoint, in terms of figuring out what
you're going to do in November, if you are
someone who is debating what to do in November
on the basis of the terror Reid situation,
there is never going to be a conclusive investigation
that tells us what happened.
OK, we you all need to understand this and
you're going to have to figure out what to
do in November without a conclusion from an
investigation.
And the reason that it's not going to happen
is that it essentially cannot happen, given
what we know.
I mean, explain what I mean in a moment.
The reason this is important is that a lot
of people who don't like Biden and don't like
Trump are now taking advantage of the terror
Reid story to essentially not have to make
a decision about whether voting for Biden
is better than voting for Trump.
People who clearly are on Biden's side on
the issues or closer to Biden's side than
Trump's on the issues, are insisting that
until they know the truth about what happened
in the 1990s, until it's really investigated,
they can't decide.
It's time to skip to the end.
Any investigation that takes place based on
what's been made, what allegations have been
made so far would not tell you whether this
did or did not happen.
It wouldn't.
This is not just about he said she said although
it it is this is not about believe women or
don't.
As I've said before, making allegations is
very serious.
It exposes the victim to harassment and shame
and the whole thing.
It must be taken seriously when a victim makes
an allegation.
This is simply about all that I'm talking
about now is that there could not possibly
be based on everything we know right now,
a conclusive investigation.
There's a bigger topic as well, which is can
someone prove they did not commit a sexual
assault when the allegations themselves are
like the ones we have here?
There's only a very narrow way that you could
prove you did not commit a sexual assault.
And that would be like imagine that Terry
Reid filed a complaint on a specific day.
And we saw, oh, the allegation is that this
supposedly took place.
This day and then Bidens travel schedule from
that time shows he was out of the country.
OK, maybe in that narrow scenario you could
conclude he didn't do it.
But beyond that, you can't really prove you
didn't commit sexual assault.
And in this particular case, we can't even
find the complaint.
Biden said release certain records, but he
hasn't said release others.
Tara Reid doesn't have a copy of the complaint.
She previously said the complaint was for
sexual assault.
Now she says the complaint she did file doesn't
mention sexual assault, but it describes sexual
harassment.
But there's no copy of the complaint.
So what I am telling you is not that she's
telling the truth or that she's lying.
We should take her allegations seriously.
But there is not a complaint to investigate.
Joe Biden cannot prove his innocence, nor
is there any way to confirm Tara Reid's allegations.
There couldn't be a conclusive investigation.
Now, what about this idea that's floating
around that she was fired because of the complaint
that she filed?
It's such a mess at this point that no investigation
could conclude anything.
She says she was fired for filing the complaint.
We can't find there's a negative performance
review on file whose timing can be used to
call this into question.
Well, what if you go and talk to witnesses?
Well, Terry Reid says she approached three
Biden aides about this back in the 90s.
All three of those people told The New York
Times they don't know anything about it.
Could they have forgotten?
Sure.
Could they be lying?
But the point is, it would be like the Cavenagh
investigation, where it is impossible to conclude
this happened or this didn't happen.
Given that there is no way that an investigation
would ever tell us Biden did it or Biden didn't
do it, the message is you're going to have
to decide whether you prefer Trump or Biden
to be president.
I think there are lots of people who would
love a way out of voting for Joe Biden and
would see Biden did it as a bailout, that
they need to feel okay about taking an action
that helps reelect Donald Trump.
Listen, the DNC screwed itself.
They selected a sexual assaulter.
They lost my vote.
But that investigation is not going to happen.
And you're going to have to decide on the
issues.
Now, does any of this clear, Biden?
Of course not.
There's almost no way Biden could be cleared
again if it was determined that on the day
Tara Reid claims this happened, Biden was
in China.
That might clear him, but you'd still have
people say, oh, I'm sure Tara Regis doesn't
remember the right date.
If the investigation determined as almost
every single one of these do, that it cannot
find evidence to confirm terror Reid story,
nor can it find evidence to disprove terror
Reid's story.
People will read that as whatever they want.
Either it happened, but there's not enough
evidence.
Maybe because the evidence was suppressed,
people will come up with that or people will
say, see, I told you, there's no evidence
that this thing happened.
It doesn't matter in the end because you are
going to need to decide.
Given that there will never be such a conclusion,
you will need to decide what is better for
the country in November.
I'm not going to evangelize my point of view.
You all know the calculation I've made.
You were going to have to make the same calculation
without the benefit of a conclusive investigation,
which there will never be.
There may be an investigation.
There is no way.
Given what we know, that it would be conclusive
and give you the answer many of you are waiting
for.
You disagree.
Let me know.